hey i need your help  i've lost contact with benedict mcadams  and the driver who was supposed to get  him out of town  head to the coordinates i gave you see  what you can find  more details  so did you think it over  well of course if you can't fit it in  your budget  too scary  [Music]  [Music]  or  see militech's been investing in young  talent  joe you here to take me on a little  field trip  i'm here on dakota's behalf for christ's  sakes  now you're telling me i loathe it this  whole  playing tough in the face of death thing  all right let's get you out of here [ __ ]  i feel like i haven't used my legs for a  straight month  [Music]  hey  hmm  those sweet honey melons dakota folks  got growing  [Music]  jason entertained  hey mcadams over here  starkey it's been years  you look like [ __ ]  i'm a bit indisposed looks like you'll  have to be my chauffeur  avi fyi dakota's sending over your  payment  nova thanks have a good one